he's won more than any manager now in
the Premier League and he spent the most
but how successful is Pep Guardiola
more than arsene Wenger with the longest
and beaten run
also Alex Ferguson with his record 13
lead titles we've been through three
decades of Premier League finances to
discover which manager gets the best
value for money out of their squads it's
not Pep Guardiola winner of five Premier
League titles here at Manchester City
it's the less glamorous Sean dice
considered the most effective manager in
premier league history he's achieved the
most with the least
we found that dice while at Burnley
gained the most premier league places
compared to the wage Bill ranking he's
an over performer who Everton turned to
in January for a relegation struggle
that will only be settled on Sunday
leads are in the same fight and this is
why they parachuted some other dice in
three weeks ago he makes our top five
with Maurizio pochettino Tony pulis and
Gordon Strachan are statistically the
most successful managers on the other
end of the scale though the special one
turns out not so special despite three
League titles at Chelsea Jose Mourinho
significantly underachieved based on his
resources Financial strength Club good
players many many reasons I'm not stupid
to realize without this incredible clubs
I've been I could not achieve what we
achieve he's been at City Seven Seasons
rare longevity in The Dugout especially
in this season with a record 14 managers
being sacked
clubs hope new bosses produce immediate
wins a bounce initially achieved when
dice replaced Frank Lampard at Everton
but the form dropped
Nathan Jones couldn't reverse fortunes
to keep Southampton up allodice can
still at Leeds
Thomas Frank has shown how to exceed
expectations at Brentford so what are
the secrets of success in The Dugout
Clear Vision
consistent in messages
consistent Behavior
every single day I think that's key the
key we found to judge in managerial
success isn't always the Trope is one
but how they make the most out of the
cash they have to spend
Rob Harris Sky News
[Applause]